أعذرني على المقاطعة ولكن السؤال
اللطيف لم ينجح في نشر مقطع فيديو
لناشط في مجال تغير المناخ يواجه
السكرتير الصحفي للبيت الأبيض كريم
جان بيير على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، حيث
كتب مليون شاب إلى
الإدارة يطالبون بعدم
الموافقة على التنقيب عن النفط الكارثي
مشروع في ألاسكا وتم تجاهلنا لذلك
أنا هنا أقوم بتوجيه قوة
أسلافي وجيلي، هل ستتوقف
الإدارة عن
الموافقة على مشاريع النفط والغاز الجديدة
وتتماشى مع مجتمعات شباب العلوم ومجتمعات
الخطوط الأمامية من
المنحدر الشمالي لألاسكا إلى لويزيانا إليز  يوشي،
المدير التنفيذي لجيل Z
للتغيير، انتقد
إدارة بايدن بسبب موافقتها على
مشاريع النفط والغاز، لقد
وافقت على مشاريع متعددة
منذ ذلك الحين وأكثر بمعدل أسرع
من إدارة ترامب، نحن بحاجة
إليك للوفاء بوعود حملتك الانتخابية